well for all of 2016 and most of the
three years since then Hillary Clinton
has been begging America to just forget
about her emails the use of my email
account was turned into you know the
biggest scandal since lord knows when
they covered it like it was Pearl Harbor
this week though weirdly Clinton appears
to be reversing course in the strangest
way possible on Tuesday she appeared at
an art exhibition in Venice Italy the
exhibition features a copy of the
resolute desk one from the Oval Office
with a printed stack of all the emails
recovered from her private server
Hillary Clinton spent an hour at the
exhibition sitting down to read her
emails then declaring them quote boring
but it wasn't boring it was weird as
hell and that's why we picked up the red
phone and called mark Stein brought him
here to explain what just happened mark
what do you make of this well I think as
Bernie Sanders said whatever it was now
four years ago I'm sick to death of your
Damn emails that was the point by the
way I think that Bernie lacked lost the
Democrat nomination because it showed
that unlike Trump with low-energy
Jeb he lacked the killer instinct I
think everybody I think Bernie's right
though other Democrats are sick to death
of your Damn emails so Hillary turning
itself into a piece of performance art
and actually going to the Venice
Biennale in Italy and sitting behind a
replica of the Oval Office desk with
every single print out of all her extant
emails and and the point to remember
about this sucker is she actually called
the Venice Biennale and said oh I happen
to be in the neighborhood I don't know
whether that means he was in Monte Carlo
or Albania or wherever it was and can I
come and be part of it that that shows a
woman who simply refuses to get off the
stage no matter how many hooks they try
to pull her off with it does seem a
little strange because even her husband
who you know famously loved affirmation
and human contact to the point
where you know he exposed himself
completely even he is kind of receded
from the public view and has in effect
retired from public life Hillary Clinton
you'd think would be with her
grandchildren why is she doing this
well I think I don't think she's given
up on somebody picking up the phone
after a couple months more of debates
Joe Biden is sagging his lifeless
he's a front runner who nobody's
enthusiastic about in other words he's
exactly where she was four years ago now
this at this stage Hillary is dreaming
that they'll say oh we need you to come
back Hillary third time's the charm
we're all desperate for you we're
waiting for you she's got a book out the
again it's been timed to release with
the start of the presidential season
she's sucking she's happy when she's
sucking up Biden's airtime and Bernie's
airtime and Elizabeth Warren's and it's
exactly the 27 dwarves who were left in
and that's why she's doing it she still
dreams the call is gonna come you're
totally right and I don't know why I
hadn't thought of that but it's it's
clearly true mark Stein great to see you
tonight thank you for that